you release one comedy special in 2023
not our guest
Jeff Leach is going to release three
comedy specials this year and he joins
us in studio good to have you with us
thank you very much you'll be like the
Unholy Trinity you're currently dropping
over the course of the Year lovely to be
here man it was great to have you for
the last 10 minutes it is it's been fun
talking to you I knew immediately you
were from England by the accident you
did not call me Australian and then
South Africa I know I guessed about a
million places before World Travel
gentleman who knows his accents this has
gone so well for you over the last some
odd years right how long have you rich
Jackson in this country I meant being a
comedian but yes that too how long has
this been a goal of yours and how long
have you been on this track you know
what's funny is I I started out my
career doing similar to what you do I
used to host for the BBC on TV back in
the UK and then um The Comedy seller
which is one of the most famous if not
the most famous venue in this country
now in New York City and they've got a
venue here in Vegas where I'll be
performing uh they brought me over to
America about seven years ago and I've
never really looked back since then you
know it's just been a video game after
TV show after animated series you have a
video game series multiple video games
yeah yeah what kind of video games Call
of Duty valorant Total War okay a number
of large franchises that's fantastic and
just to make sure we do get this out you
are at the Rio right I'm staying uh I'm
not staying there but yes I'm performing
at the Rio in The Comedy Cellar uh-huh
two shows a night I believe seven and
nine thirty p.m and that will be every
single day until this Sunday okay and
it's totally clean from what you tell me
absolutely yeah okay that's probably my
children allowed it's definitely an
adult set in fact I can see you've muted
the audio on the footage because it was
that disgusting we couldn't find one
five second snippet but you do however
have a series coming out that is for
kids I do indeed yes on YouTube
Originals um it's gonna be some kids
programming called Jam van uh it's
myself Pete Lee Mark Maron a whole host
of amazing Comedians and that Launches
on the 19th a week from now so if you've
got youngsters you can let them watch
Jam van and then if you want to see
something a bit more adult come and see
me at the arena I can tell you just a
fun hang you're having a blast doing
what you're doing are we gelling right
now I hope so I hope so you go to Wine
uh well no and I'm thinking maybe
something you know a little something
something just two guys maybe go and try
on some suits later on get a couple of
cigars right swimsuits the whole nine
yards right massage we'll see oh no
their sky's the limit there's no there's
no limit he's playing with the earpiece
so get him off get him off that's the
producer go and stop stop
but yeah no I I think uh it's always
good to have a little bond with people
and empathize with people and find
connection any way you can and I do that
on stage as well that's what my comedy
is about so it's very interactive it's
very interactive every show is different
because I'd love to do stuff with the
audience so it's about them but then
also I talk about very personal things
you know about love and heartbreak and
raising children and getting older
things that anyone can relate to I hope
uh and then there's a few dirty jokes as
well for the love it for the filthy
amongst you Jeff Leach can't wait to see
your special I love that you're in town
and entertainment